um i wanted to just say a few words
before we start so i'm shafi goldwater
i'm the director here of simon's
institute and i want to first of all
thank all of you for joining
us at the 10th anniversary symposium and
the simons institute um for the theory
of computing was established in july 1st
2012 so 10 years ago with a very uh
generous grant from the simon's
foundation
and the vision of its founders which
were descartes alistair sinclair
christos papa dimitri and umash bazrani
at the time was to promote fundamental
research on the foundation's computer
science as well as to expand the
horizons of the field by exploring other
scientific adjacent fields through what
they called it the time computational
lens
and the concept which has uh maybe
borrowed from msri uh also is to bring
together
uh leaders world leaders international
computer science and other fields as
well as the next generation of scholars
um to explore unsolved problems
and the nature and limit of computation
and um in the decades since its founding
the institute has done
exactly that
there have been about 40 programs and
clusters
200 workshops
lots of open problems solved and new
problems defined
and uh in areas as
diverse as markets genomics quantum
physics machine learning causality this
time and more
uh so sort of all over the place and i
think that in so doing we've expanded
the borders of the world computer
science and um
also trained the next generation the way
that the promise has been uh
you know we've delivered on it and i
personally joined the institute in 2018
and
my colleagues and leadership team first
of all peter where's peter bartlett
there's peter stand up you're so tall
everybody will see you yeah
so really
i mean a major hand of applause to peter
who's done the you know an incredible
job in in running the institute and uh
deserves all thanks
um
much more than probably he gets
because it gets a lot of headaches but
really i'm incredibly grateful and also
luca trevison was not here but he was a
senior scientist and when i started and
then was joined by prasad bhagavendra is
prasad here
uh he will be and uh
easy where are you get up oh thank you
[Applause]
and uh
and lately by venkat gore swami who came
from carnegie mellon and i know he's not
feeling well today but he will be here
tomorrow because he says he's feeling
better and um who has been
leading
[Applause]
who was part of the original team and
now is leading a quantum pod that we
have at uh simon's and peter is leading
a machine learning part in addition to
his
job as an associate director
so we have massively expanded also our
postdoc program uh
currently we have more than 50
and
essentially in recognition of
prominence of algorithms in everyday
life and aspects of society
we've also enhanced public understanding
of the field through having a science
communicator a position and fellowships
on society
and
aspects of ai and the law
and to the event today i guess the next
three days we're going to celebrate 10
year anniversary we're going to look
back and accomplishments and we're also
going to talk about the future the
decade the time new research directions
new insights hopefully
and um
new impact from our ideas and thrive
computer science on technology and the
world so finally what did you come here
for not to listen to me but our first
speaker who's john kleinberg and i'm so
grateful that he has
agreed to be here and be our first
speaker and john is going to talk on
modeling conflict in social media and
john has almost for three decades or
even more but he's young
uncovered fundamental principles
concerning algorithms networks the roles
they play in large-scale societal uh and
information system and has been awarded
every you know all awards and of lena
prize and many others and um
he is just uh every time i hear him i
learn something new so i'm sure that's
going to happen and i'm very grateful
[Applause]